la langue la culture créole est célébré
tous les ans et ça depuis trente-sept
années une manière de conserver de
mettre en l'air nout lang
selon des études la transmission de sa
langue maternelle se fait par la chanson
parfois dès le plus jeune âge moi je
n'ai pas été bercé par des berceuse
créole mais à ma première fille et
maintenant ma deuxième je leur chante
une petite berceuse très connue fait
dodo laminaire
est là enfants de janet
est si la mine est le dodo pas chaque
marc hovasse ou qu'à elle à la question
quelle est votre chanson créole préférer
les plus jeunes celles ci en tête des
berceuses des comptines le folklore
réunionnais beaucoup plus vaste avec des
musiques cher à nos coeurs
d'où sa nou sava alain peters ou encore
tiers mans viry et bien d'autres encore
à chacun sa préférence reste la maloja
de la nappe et adresse de la maloja
reste la maladresse de la même vie
souvient monnaiera doré le petit bouquet
vous la donne a moins
et là longtemps
les fans et cv souvient comme ça les
lois
un ti fleur fanée ou ou ou ti fleur aimé
et 10
et à moins toujours
[Musique]
quicksec l'amo
ouais
la musique réunionnaise sera l'honneur
pendant un mois sur nos ondes
l'occasion pour certains de découvrir ou
redécouvrir le patrimoine musical
réunionnais
[Musique]